قال المتحدث باسم الجيش الاسرائيلي دانييل
هاجار ان ثلاثه مدنيين كان يعتقد انهم في
اعداد المفقودين منذ السابع من اكتوبر
الماضي كشف انهم رهاء لدى حماس واعلن ها
جاري ان عدد المحتجزين في قطاع غزه يرتفع
بذلك الى
136 بينهم 24 اعلنت
وفاتهم لا يزال 36 اسرائيليا محتجزين في
قطاع غزه من بينهم ثلاثه مدنيين ابلغ عن
اختفائهم في البدايه ولكن تبين لاحقا انهم
من بين الرهائن في غزه هذا القرار تخذ في
ضوء عمليات المسح والتحقيق الشامله في
البلاد وبعد دراسه جميع السيناريوهات
المحتمله والمعلومات الاستخباراتيه
المتوفره لدينا نحن مستمرون في العمل بكل
الجهود الاستخباراتيه والميدانيه لتهيئه
الظروف اعاده الرهائن الى الوطن ويركز
حاليا على جنوب قطاع
غزه